hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing the
founding of ilvermorni School North
America's answer to Hogwarts I'll be
kicking things off by discussing the
story of its founder is old Sayer then
set going into the founding of the
school following that I'll be breaking
down the minutia of everything that we
know about ilvermorny from its own
unique house system to the school's
grounds to its curriculum and more
without further Ado I present to you the
tale of adult ser and ilvermorny school
is old Sarah was an Irish witch born
sometime around the year 1603 who spent
most of her early childhood in the
valley of Laura County Kerry is alt
came from two pure blood Wizarding
families the Sears and the gaunts her
father was William Sayre and her mother
was Rihanna gaunt who came from the
house of gaunt you may recognize the
name gaunt and that's because it's the
the same family that Voldemort comes
from descendants of Salazar said they're
in himself is old had an idyllic
childhood her family lived in the
beautiful countryside everyone was happy
and healthy and her parents had a good
relationship with their muggle neighbors
it has been expressed that Rihanna and
William would help their Muckle
neighbors with magical cures for humans
and livestock whenever possible however
this idyllic life didn't last forever as
when she was five years old both of her
parents died during an attack on the
family home is old was rescued from the
fire by her mother's estranged sister
gomla gaunt and assault was taken to the
neighboring Valley of kumkali or
pagsglen where she was raised from then
on however as assault Grew Older she
came to the realization that her Aunt
wasn't her savior she was in fact the
murderer of her parents unstable and
cruel gomla was a fanatical pure blood
who believed that her sister's
helpfulness to her muggle neighbors were
setting his result Upon A Dangerous path
to intermarriage with a non-magical man
gomla disapproved the way that assault
was being raised by her parents and in
an effort to set result on the right
path she knew that she would need to
take drastic action she believed that by
murdering assault's parents and raising
her as her own she could get her back on
track as gomla hailed from the gaunt
family she came from a long line of pure
blood radical supremacists because of
this extreme prejudice was ingrained in
her mentality this meant that she could
not sit idly by while assault was raised
in such a pure accepting manner gomla
refused to allow Ozil to take up her
place at Hogwarts when the letter
arrived on the basis that is old would
learn more at home than at a dangerously
egalitarian establishment full of
mudbloods however gomla herself had
attended Hogwarts and told assault a
great deal about the school in the main
she did this to denigrate the place
lamenting that Salazar slytherin's plans
for the purity of wizard kind had not
been fulfilled to her niece isolated and
mistreated by an aunt she believed to be
at least half insane Hogwart sounded
like a kind of paradise she spent much
of her teens fantasizing about it and
for 12 long years assault was trapped
under gormless roof isolated from the
world and suppressed in every way by her
evil Aunt however on one fateful day is
old was eventually able to Escape by
stealing her aunt's wand she knew that
she would need to travel far far away as
gormla would inevitably come looking for
her because of this assault eventually
found herself masquerading as a muggle
boy named elia's story on a ship called
the mayflower is old eventually found
herself in America amongst some of the
earlier settlers alone in a new country
assault was unsure of what her next move
would be but she eventually decided to
head to the mountains after spending
some time in the mountains assault
eventually came across a creature native
to America known as a pakwaji a short
gray-faced creature distantly related to
the European Goblin
is alt came across the puckwaji when it
was being attacked by another creature
known as a hide behind a vicious
nocturnal Beast Adept at both disguise
and disemboweling the result of
accidental breeding between a demig eyes
and a ghoul she ended up saving the
pakwaji's life and in return the pakwaji
vowed to serve her until he had an
opportunity to properly repay his debt
to her the puck what she refused to give
assault his real name which led to her
dubbing him William after her father
this was the beginning of their
adventures together while wandering in
the woods one day is old and William
came across a family who were being
attacked by the same hide behind that
had attacked William it was a family of
four two parents and their two boys and
by the time his Alton William showed up
the parents were already as good as dead
after the hide behind had been defeated
is all determined that the boys though
they were injured still stood a chance
at surviving in an effort to help save
their lives assault and William took
them home and his All Began nursing them
back to health at this point in time
result was so furious with William and
his reluctance to help save the boys
that she told him that she no longer had
any need of him and he left though she
had lost her pakwaji companion is result
had gained two new ones two boys named
Chadwick and Webster while the boys were
injured for quite some time they did
slowly begin to regain their strength
and assault was delighted when she found
out that the two boys were in fact
magical when assault felt that the boys
were in good enough Health to be left on
their own for a few hours she went out
in search of a proper burial site for
their parents and it was while searching
for this burial site that assault came
across a man by the name of James
Stewart a steward who knew the boot
family had gone into the forest to
search for them while digging the graves
for Mr and Mrs boot Stu had noticed a
wand on Mr Boots person and out of
curiosity gave it a wave because Steward
was not magical the wand rebelled
against him and it sent him flying
backwards through the air he woke in a
small shelter of branches and animal
skins to find himself being nursed by
his old she could not hide her magic
from him in such a confined space
particularly when she was brewing
potions to Aid the boot boy's recovery
and using her wand to hunt is alt
intended to obliviate James once he was
over his concussion and to send him back
to the Colony at Plymouth after James
had recovered assault was overjoyed to
have another adult around they formed a
connection with one another very quickly
and shortly after meeting they began to
build a house together on top of Mount
Greylock after the cottage had been
completed assault named it ilvermorny
after the cottage that she was born in
with every day that passed azolt told
herself that she would obliviate James
but eventually she came to the
realization that there was simply too
deep in love with the result being that
they just married is Alton James raised
the boot boys like their own children
and while they were growing up his old
would tell them stories of a magical
School named Hogwart
the boys longed to attend a magical
school but a salt who knew that
returning to Ireland could result in an
altercation with Gormley and told the
boys that she would start a school of
magic for them right there in their
Cottage the same Cottage that she dubbed
ilvermorny as they wanted to base the
school off of Hogwarts the boys were
insistent that the school have four
different houses and on that same night
the small and unusual family of Misfits
began brainstorming ideas for what these
houses would be called they eventually
decided that they would name the houses
after their favorite magical beasts and
so Thunderbird Wampus one Serpent and
pakwaji were born
when Webster turned 11 it was time for
his magical studies to begin by this
time word had spread of the family's
little cottage and the school that was
being formed and just by Word of Mouth
their first school year had a couple of
students from outside of the family year
by year however the school grew and by
the year 1634 the school had grown to
Beyond any of their expectations what
started as a small scale operation
inside of a little cottage eventually
became a massive educational Staple in
North America and the cottage expanded
into a huge castle which could
accommodate student boarding witches and
wizards were sent there from all over
North America and by the 19th century
ilvermorny had built the reputation that
it enjoys today is old and James both
lived to be over a hundred they had seen
the cottage of ilvermorny become a
granite castle and they died in the
knowledge their school was now so famous
that magical families all over North
America were clamoring to educate their
children there they had staff they had
built dormitories they'd concealed their
school from Nomad Eyes by clever
enchantments in short the girl had
dreamed of attending Hogwarts had helped
found the North American equivalent
School structure grounds as I mentioned
earlier ilford morning's impressive
Castle could be found on top of the
highest peak of Mount greylog in the
Berkshires of Western Massachusetts the
Berkshires were mountains formed over
half a billion years ago when Africa
collided with North America effectively
pushing up the Appalachian Mountains and
forming the Bedrock of the Berkshires
erosion over hundreds of millions of
years has worn these mountains down to
what we see today and the average
elevation of the Berkshires ranges from
700 to 1200 feet however its high points
were in excess of 3000 feet which is
where ilvermorny resides just like
Hogwarts ilvermornyat concealment charms
hiding its exact location but in
ilvermorny's case these enchantments hid
the school in a wreath of Misty cloud
provided that ivomoni's immense
structure sprouted from a small Granite
Stone House it's likely that the castle
was built up using similar materials
however one notable characteristic of
the school was that its front doors were
adorned with marble statues of both
assault ser and James Stewart houses and
sorting ceremony provided that
ilvermorny was so heavily based off of
Hogwarts it shouldn't surprise you that
ilvermorny not only adopted the house
system but also the Sorting ceremony let
me indulge you with some information
about both topics the Sorting ceremony
at ilvermorny is also similar to the
ceremony at Hogwarts with students being
brought up one by one to have their
house chosen for them however Ivan won
his process doesn't involve a dirty hat
and instead enlist the help of Enchanted
carvings one by one students are called
to stand on the symbol of the gordian
knot set into the middle of the stone
floor in Silence the school then waits
for the enchanted carvings to react if
the horns serpent once the student the
crystal set into its forehead will light
up if the Wampus wants a student it
Roars the Thunderbird signifies its
approval by beating its wings and the
pakwaji will raise its Arrow into the
air and if two or more carvings should
happen to react to a student at once
then the decision lies with the student
to choose their house for themselves
onto the houses the four houses of
ilvermorny are Thunderbird Wampus Fawn
Serpent and pankwaji aptly named after
the favorite magical beasts of each
founder horned serpent was chosen by
assault Wampus by Webster Thunderbird by
Chadwick and pakwaji by James
Thunderbirds are extremely powerful
magical birds that Eclipse even the
powers of the fabled phoenix like the
Phoenix and its Association to the
element of fire Thunderbirds more
closely resonate with aspects of thunder
and lightning Thunderbirds can command
the weather and create powerful targeted
storms whenever they want additionally
there are meant in size of Incredible
strength and possess huge powerful
Talons like the Phoenix their feathers
can be taken and used in the Wonder core
the vanderberg calls are said to be
particularly powerful at Transfiguration
Wampus cats are magical cats native to
the Appalachians that heavily resemble
mountain lions or cougars but while they
heavily resemble a common mountain lion
they are very different able to walk on
their hind legs and perform legellimency
hypnosis using their yellow eyes
Wampus cats were said to be fast strong
and almost impossible to kill it's also
worth mentioning that the tears of a
Wampus cat had strong degenerative
properties if just a few drops were
ingested the Drinker would begin to
rapidly lose their memory horned
serpents were intelligent magical snakes
that boasted a horn on their head and
could be found in different parts of the
world there were several different
species of horned serpents with results
there running into the one most commonly
found in North America the natural
habitats of foreign serpents were bodies
of water and they were known to emit a
low musical note to sound Danger
are short gray-faced large-eared
creatures distantly related to the
European Goblin fiercely independent
tricky and not over fond of humankind
whether magical or mundane it possesses
its own powerful magic
bakwaji's hunt with deadly poisonous
arrows and they enjoy playing tricks on
humans but with the creatures
representing each house to find one big
question remains what does being sorted
into each house mean what does it tell
us about the young ritual wizard that
sorted before answering this I think
it's important to mention that while
Hogwarts views each house as its own
distinct entity ilvermorny has a more
all-encompassing approach viewing each
house as one part of a whole
it is sometimes said of the ilvermorny
houses that they represent the whole
witch or wizard the mind is represented
by horned serpent the body Wampus the
heart pakwaji and the Soul Thunderbird
others say that horned serpent favors
Scholars Wampus Warriors bakwaji healers
and Thunderbird adventurers so
regardless of where you're sorted you
are still connected to the other houses
in some way while examining these houses
I couldn't help but look at them through
a hogwarts-centric Viewpoint desperately
trying to identify the Hogwarts
equivalents but in truth the houses at
ilvermorny are entirely their own Wampus
is sort of Gryffindor and horned serpent
is sort of Ravenclaw but it's just not
that simple after the Sorting ceremony
it ended students were then brought to a
large Hall where they were chosen once
more This Time by a wand
uniform while the Robes of Hogwarts
students were influenced by the house
that they had been sorted into
ilvermorny didn't adopt this practice
the robes for all students of ilvermorny
were blue and cranberry blue because it
was his old's favorite color because she
always wanted to be a Ravenclaw and
cranberry simply because James happened
to love cranberry pie the blue and
cranberry robes were also fastened by a
gold gordian knot in memory of the
brooch is alt found in the ruins of the
original ilflamorni Cottage curriculum
while Hogwarts boasts 21 subjects 23 if
you count subjects branched off from
core subjects there isn't as much
available information out there on the
curriculum of ilvermorny however we do
know that they teach the following
defense against the dark arts is a class
that teaches students defensive
techniques to defend themselves against
the dark arts and to protect themselves
from dark creatures one of the
professors of the subject was Rihanna
Steward the daughter of ilvermorny
Founders result Sayer and James Stewart
John's class teaches students how to
perform spells that add different
properties to objects or individuals
jamb students at devil morning used
Chadwick's charms volumes 1 to 7 written
by founder Chadwick boot as their
standard textbook for the class an award
called the charms chalice was given to
students who excelled in the subject
Transfiguration class teaches students
how to change the form or appearance of
an object to celebrate this field of
study ilvermorny held a contest between
students called the Transfiguration
tournament
potions class involves the creation of
mixtures serums and liquids with magical
properties potion making is a very
methodical process that requires the
correct mixing and stirring of
ingredients at the right times and
temperatures
xylomancy class taught students an often
overlooked method of divination
involving Twigs arithmancy is a branch
of magic concerned with the magical
properties of numbers those who excelled
in the subject at hilver morning
received an award named the arithmancy
achievement accolade
the study of ancient runes is a
theoretical subject that involves the
studying of ancient runic Scripts
creature care is the same as Hogwarts
care of magical creatures a class that
instructs students on how to care for
Magical beasts Headmasters staff while
ilvermorny has undoubtedly employed many
a professor over the years very few are
on record known Headmasters include
result Sayer James Stewart and the
current acklebert Fontaine descendant of
theodad Fontaine one of the original 12
auras in the U.S known professors
include Rihanna Steward younger daughter
fazolser and James Stewart who taught
defense against the dark arts and eulali
Hicks professor of charms and keeper of
keys that we see in the latest Fantastic
Beasts film The Secrets of Dumbledore I
wish there was more info on the teachers
of ilvermorny but that's all we've got
at the moment famous graduates but while
we don't have a massive amount of
information pertaining to the professors
of the school we do know a fair bit
about some of its more high-profile
graduates
Seraphina pickery was an American Way
true served as the president of the
magical Congress of the United States of
America from 1920 to 1928. in childhood
Seraphina was sorted into horned serpent
another member of makusa Holly Blackbird
was an American witch that specialized
in protecting hodags from no matches
while studying at ilvermorny Blackbird
was sorted into Thunderbird house
the next two notable graduates are
sisters Tina and Queenie Goldstein
protagonists in the recent Fantastic
Beasts films during their time at
ilvermorny Tina and Queenie were sorted
into Thunderbird and pakwaji
respectively the school song the
illumoni school song was cut from the
films so it's a little unclear if it
should be considered Canon or not but
here it is nonetheless we stand as one
United against the Puritan we draw our
inspiration from Good Witch Morrigan for
she was persecuted by Common wonderless
men so she fled from distant Island and
so our school began oh ilvermorny
Massachusetts we choose it we choose it
the wizard School Supreme your castle
walls they kept us safe the days with
you a dream you taught us all our magic
and now on things quite clear where we
roam where we roam our one true home our
one and owned is ilvermorny dear Legacy
given that ilvermoni was founded by no
match it shouldn't surprise you to hear
that ilvermorny earned itself a
reputation as the most democratic of all
the great Wizarding schools and long
after the passing of both assault and
James ilvermorny continued to attract
students from all over North America
ilvermory's reputation continued to
increase over the years and it
eventually became a boarding school
taking in students from across North
America more teachers were hired to meet
the demand and the house was expanded to
a castle where the 19th century it had
gained an international reputation and
by the 1920s it was considered one of
the greatest Wizarding schools in the
world and that's it for this video did
you know the history of ilvermorny what
its houses were what subjects it taught
if you learned something in this video
please leave a comment down below and as
always if you enjoy the content please
like the video and subscribe to the
channel until next time remember it
doesn't not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live